me dit blanche les noms me viennent se
reposer l'été on a dénombré foresti y on
ne dénombre de jardin on ne dénombre 2
ferme la magie des gants elle ressemble
étrangement à la magie du père noël des
fruits dire des dix lutte un peu importe
il phare fait d accepter qu'elle jure
elle l'année donc là enfin est avec
soheil année long il s'agit de venir ici
le par les samedis à partir de peu près
d'un renard alors prendre le président
lula s'est tué dix familles jeu déjà vu
en béton au feu distincts va rentrer
dans la cachette on voit des enfants
c'est qu'ils se promènent derby de
l'aude société le premier porte que vous
ce que les gens disent enfin laisser les
messages depuis nombreuses charges et 15
août
cela éclaire nos militants prennent
connaissance puis mais il me dépose un
endroit secret il ya un hic ce sont donc
je viens tous les jours pour les
rapports seraient moins 50 des parts
affaire les normes c'est arrivé
de manière une façon bien à nadine
j'avais vu chez un monsieur qui avait
des bus vides
puis j'ai décidé d'arrêter plus demandés
commun qui vend des six mois fait un bon
prix prochain avec les buts vides le
j'ai fait ma première maison de nos
loges vraiment le lavage une partie de
ça s'est su que ce qu'on dit c'est comme
une traînée de poudre qu'on conduit les
enfants du quartier sont accourus des
puces à s arrête pas depuis octobre 2006
j'aimerais que bk maco devient là comme
qu'on dit la pierre angulaire d'une omlt
au québec
moi personne à une main ce que je dois
they que je crois au nom parce qu'il y
en a qui viennent ici il y en avoir
moi j'y crois pas du tout mais excepté
que je crois que la magie dénommé les
l'existence je pourrais pas le fait un
peu comme quelqu'un qui s'en vont dans
la brouette en forêt et st on peut pas
donner le mot savez ce que je sens bien
le nommer faisceau donc qu'un génie
civil
[Musique]